Good Times create weak people weak
people create bad times bad times create
strong people strong people great great
times what I want people to get is you
got to know where you are in your life
and where you are in history and you got
to learn to take advantage of it you
can't complain that it's winter during
winter if you start a business in Winter
and you succeed 60% of all Fortune 1,000
companies that are alive today the
biggest some most successful companies
could have been born in any one of those
Four Seasons they were all born in
Winter wow a recession or depression
from FedEx to Disney Disney was
depression FedEx was a recession I can
walk you through them mall so that
process makes you strong and what
changed my life was finding that part
that's inside of all of us that will not
give up you know I'm proud to be a good
human being I believe I'm a good human
being but I think hunger often comes not
always often comes from having gone
through enough pain like I've suffered
enough I don't want somebody else to
suffer anger only gets you so far it's a
fuel that burns out very quickly now
let's take a second one
do you tend to focus more I'm sure I
know what the answer on this one is more
on what you can or can't control there's
three decisions we make every moment of
our Liv the first decision we're making
is what are we going to focus on right
now there's millions of things we could
focus on people listening could be
focused on what they're doing what we're
saying whe they matters or not you know
a million things right but we only focus
on a small band of things and whatever
we focus on we experience in life but
then the second decision you make as
soon as you focus on something as you
give it a meaning is this the end of the
beginning if you think it's the end of a
relationship you're going to behave very
different than the beginning is this
person dissing me are they challenging
me are they coaching me or are they
actually loving me whatever meaning you
create produces emotion and those
emotions control your third decision
which is what are you going to do we
don't experience life we experience life
we focus on